hey guys i'm abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen in today's edition of
what I in the day YouTube refuse I'm
going to be taking a look at Sierra
schultzy now Sierra started her YouTube
channel in 2015 and has since amassed
over 1.1 million subscribers on her main
channel she also has a vlog channel but
she shares with her husband Steven and a
podcast channel that she shares with her
best friend
now Sierra's channels cover a bit of
everything from beauty fashion body
positivity self-love and acceptance
pregnancy recipes marriage reviews Tryon
hauls everything I mean she does it all
most recently though Sierra has been a
very honest and candid on her channel
about her experience with weight gain
miscarriage and PCOS which I've
discussed on my channel when it comes to
my personal struggles right here now
Sierra doesn't do any traditional what I
today videos but she has been working
with a dietitian to help her manage her
PCOS so we're gonna be taking a look at
Sierra's meal plans and recipes as she
shares on her channels since learning
about her diagnosis now Before we jump
into my review I want to sort with my
general disclaimer that the information
in this video is for entertainment and
educational purposes only and you should
always seek out the help of a registered
dietitian or medical professional for
your unique case also a bit of a
reminder to please be kind in the
comments both here and on Sierra's
channels I do not want to see any body
shaming going on on that note let's meet
Sierra please excuse the lack of footage
we had to use images only for this video
but definitely check out the timestamps
for the full clips
[Music]
so I think it's so great that seer is
meeting with a body-positive dietitian
who seems to take on an intuitive eating
approach this is so important because so
many people with PCOS are simply just
told to lose weight but if you watch my
video on PCOS where I also interviewed a
body-positive dietitian who specializes
in PCOS you might know that dieting can
actually sometimes even worsen PCOS
symptoms by messing with sensitive
hormones like insulin testosterone and
cortisol this is already problematic for
people with PCOS so you can see how
restrictive diets can often do more harm
than good let's take a look at some of
the recommendations made by Ciara's our
Dean
[Music]
love this I am totally stealing naked
carbs and saying that because that's
just so fun but yes I 100% agree with
this recommendation insulin resistance
is a common symptom of PCOS which is
basically what happens when the cells in
the body are less responsive to insulin
basically insulin is like the key that
opens the door to the cells to let
glucose inside in order to provide us
with the fuel and energy that we need
when something is wrong with the key aka
insulin the door of the cell won't open
leaving glucose trapped in the
bloodstream resulting in higher blood
sugar levels unfortunately if not
managed through lifestyle or medication
long-term insulin resistance may
increase the risk of pre-diabetes and
eventually type-2 diabetes so just as
Sierra's Rd recommended you would
ideally want to pair carbohydrates with
a protein to help slow down the sugar
absorption which will allow blood sugar
levels and insulin to remain even keeled
this is also exactly aligned with the
suggestions that we got from Julie Duffy
Dillon in our PCOS video here now
another recommendation that I might make
is to choose higher fiber carbs of more
often as they tend to offer a lower
glycemic index if you're unfamiliar with
the glycemic index it's basically a
scale that ranks different carb
containing foods by how much they raise
blood sugar levels after being consumed
so foods that have a high glycemic index
like white bread for example will
increase blood sugar levels faster than
foods with a low glycemic index like
sourdough or whole grain bread research
has also shown that low glycemic index
diets for people with PCOS have shown
improvements in not only insulin
resistance but also menstrual regularity
now that doesn't mean that you can't
have refined carbs ever but the
suggestion would be to then pair them
with a protein like we already talked
about to reduce the overall total
glycemic load another suggestion for the
management of blood sugar levels is to
ensure that meals are spaced out evenly
through
the day some studies suggests that
eating six times a day has a more
favorable impact on insulin sensitivity
for people with PCOS so that might look
like having three meals a day with
snacks in between or eating something
every two to three hours this will
ensure that blood sugar levels remain
even throughout the day as there is a
consistent flow of fuel to the body
let's see what else she suggested
[Music]
so PCOS and soy is a pretty
controversial topic and it can be
confusing to figure out whether soy is
good or bad when it comes to hormonal
regulation basically soy is a
phytoestrogen that sometimes mimics the
body's natural estrogen which is
responsible for the regulation of female
reproductive hormones at this point
however the majority of the research on
soy intake and PCOS has been largely
positive research on PCOS has shown that
phytoestrogens can improve lipid
profiles by lowering triglycerides and
cholesterol levels thereby reducing the
risk of heart disease other research has
shown that soy consumption may improve
reproductive hormones by lowering the
levels of testosterone and luteinizing
hormone which are often higher than
normal and people with PCOS other
research on PCOS has shown that
phytoestrogens can also improve insulin
resistance by increasing insulin
sensitivity which as I mentioned is
really important for people with PCOS to
help reduce the risk of type 2 diabetes
however there is some research
suggesting that soy may aggravate
symptoms of PCOS specifically for those
with thyroid issues due to the
goitrogenic effect of soy interfering
with the uptake of iodine so maybe that
was part of the artis thinking now when
it comes to reproduction specifically
one 2010 review did caution against
consuming soy protein in excess because
it may lead to reduced
ovarian function and lower ganado tropen
levels which are of course important for
reproduction
one study found that consuming more than
a hundred milligrams of soy a day can
result in these negative effects however
the majority of studies reviewed
suggests that about 10 to 15 milligrams
of soy a day which is about one to two
servings were not shown to pose any
harmful effects on reproduction so
because we know that sea air is trying
to conceive the recommendation to limit
soy may be appropriate for her unique
goals as for the goat's milk
recommendation this does make total
sense for someone like Sierra who may
need more protein in her diet as we want
to focus on upping our protein when it
comes to managing PCOS
her usual almond milk only provides
around a grand per cup soy milk would
have around seven grams but again she's
been advised to limit soy so goat's milk
has about nine grams of protein per cup
so it's a star so this is definitely a
great option for Sierra to meet her
needs so it sounds like Sierra had a
positive experience with her dietitian
which is so great to hear and I totally
agree that small manageable changes are
definitely more sustainable in the long
run rather than being overwhelmed with
making too many changes too quickly I
also love that when Sierra talks about
nourishing her body she uses descriptive
words like feeling healthy good and
strong rather than focusing on weight
loss or fat loss okay so now let's see
how her meal planning goes
[Music]
okay that is a great recommendation so
we have the protein from the protein
powder and goat's milk in the protein
shake and some carbs from the banana in
the shake as well and the addition of
the string cheese or nuts on the side
will add some of those fats in there
which would obviously make this a really
satiating breakfast to keep her blood
sugar levels in check
yes so all excellent snack options Greek
yogurt provides that hunger crushing
combination of protein and fat and the
addition of extra carbs and fiber from
the raspberries and granola really
routes us out nicely carrots and hummus
are also a great choice because we've
got some protein fiber and fat in the
hummus and more fiber and carbs in the
carrots she could also throw in some
whole-grain crackers or some cheese on
days that maybe she was feeling like she
needed a little bit something more
satiating but all great options so far
so let's hear about lunch
so I love that Sierra's meal planning in
the context of her busy work week so
instead of picking up some takeout or
potentially missing lunch entirely
she's piecing together a simple
on-the-go meal so a caloric and
nutritionally dense energy bar paired
with some nuts on the side can be a
small quick lunch on the go all I would
suggest is maybe throwing in you know
some of those baby carrots or hummus
that she was talking about as an extra
snack that day just to make sure that
we're getting in some veg and probably
to plan for a larger dinner that day
since this is a smaller meal and a
busier day but I also love the sound of
that black bean Bowl so let's take a
look at dinner
[Music]
okay so again we're seeing the
dieticians carb plus protein pairing
recommendation in action whether it's
the falafel with brown rice on Greek
night or the beans and brown rice for
veggie fajitas night and I love that she
actually does end up planning for a
larger dinner on her busy work day
knowing that she'll likely be hungry or
that day overall I think that cierra did
an amazing job implementing the
recommendations that had been made for
her by her dietician she not only
considered the things that she likes but
also did a really great job anticipating
how her busier work days may impact her
nutritional needs that day
honestly if Sierra was my client I would
be really proud okay so while I have
tried to switch to reviewing people's
days as a whole that doesn't really work
in the context of Sierra's channel
because she doesn't really do a whole
lot of what I in a day videos so we are
going to take a look at her choices meal
by meal let's start with breakfast okay
so while I totally think that rx bars
are a great snack and I love that they
use really simple ingredients there's
only like 200 calories here so we could
maybe pair it with some nuts or yogurt
and fruit or just like a piece of whole
grain toast that would help prevent any
drops in energy and blood sugar
fluctuations but I do know however that
in this video she's still just kind of
getting used to the idea of having
breakfast period so I do think that the
bar is an easy and convenient way to
kind of just edge into that habit let's
take a look at another breakfast okay so
now that Sierra has gotten into the
breakfast routine I love that she's
taking another kind of breakfast step up
with this yogurt and pumpkin seed combo
so here we've got some protein in the
yogurt plus some fat and extra fiber in
the seeds and it's still really easy to
make now when she's ready for step three
she could like add some berries or
banana on top for a little extra fiber
and energizing carbs but in general
I really like this step let's take a
look at breakfast three like she just
totally listened to my suggestions so I
love that but now she has taken that
protein-rich Greek yogurt with the fiber
and healthy fats from the walnuts and
pumpkin seeds and has added in some
carbs from the banana and berries and
the walnuts specifically are an actual
great nut choice since research suggests
that consuming more omega-3 fats like
those found in walnuts may help reduce
insulin resistance and cholesterol
levels in people with PCOS so yay -
thumbs up for this meal let's take a
look at some of Sierra's lunch and
dinner meals okay so I love this little
ode to Greek yogurt because it's also a
huge staple of mine because like she
said it has 29 grams of protein in one
cup now the one thing I would say is she
is using like a fat-free yogurt is we
don't have to fear higher fat dairy
there is Ashley research to support that
higher fat dairy is not associated with
cardiovascular disease metabolic
syndrome or even weight gain over time
which I know seems counterintuitive
there's also research to suggest that
compared with low-fat dairy full fat
dairy actually has lower levels of
androgens
not to mention intakes of lower fat
dairy but not full fat dairy has been
shown to increase the risk of ovulation
related infertility not to mention the
extra fat will again help slow down any
insulin response and most will agree
that thought that just tastes better so
when I do consume dairy I don't usually
bother with fat-free now I know a lot of
you watching do not do dairy so other
plant-based sources of protein that are
not soy based that Ciera could throw
into the rotation could include beans
nuts powdered peanut butter or nut
butter cheese eggs and hemp seeds as for
this feel I love that we're seeing lower
glycemic index carbs on board like sweet
potato bell pepper and quinoa plus the
protein in the Greek yogurt my only
small suggestion would be to maybe pump
up the veggies a little bit maybe throw
in another bell pepper or some leafy
beans green beans or something like that
but overall this looks like a really
hearty meal let's take a look at another
option okay so simple satisfying and
delicious looking we've got our carbs
from the farro and corn protein from the
black beans plus some healthy fats from
the avocado and also some high fiber veg
in there I also totally love that Sierra
acknowledges how filling this meal was
for her and just honors her hunger by
eating until she was full and satisfied
and not feeling the need to necessarily
clean her plate let's take a look at
another option so this looks like a
great no fuss socially distanced Easter
meal now as we know we ideally want
Sierra's meals to be paired with some
source of protein especially because
she's having potatoes which are a high
glycemic index food however even though
we're not seeing a traditional protein
source quinoa does provide about 8 grams
of protein per cup while also having a
low glycemic index plus the dollop of
Greek yogurt and the trace amounts of
protein in the potatoes and the broccoli
so the total protein is about 14 grams
in this meal not bad but maybe we could
actually add some nutritional yeast to
the potatoes which would give them a
really delicious cheesy flavor or add
some Greek yogurt in there to make them
extra creamy or we could throw some
canned beans into the quinoa pilaf as
you know I don't love food rolls but if
you need a little structure I like to
roughly aim to fill half of my plate
with vegetables a quarter with my carbs
and a quarter with my protein having
said that like if this was Sierra's
Easter meal I mean I really need to shut
my mouth right now because PCOS or not
holiday meals are not meant to be
perfectly balanced and honestly this
looks pretty damn nutritious to me let's
take a look at another dinner okay so
this is not fancy or Instagram a bowl
but I love that we're leaning on our
pantry staples I also love that she's
rocking the nutritional yeast here
not only for its cheesy flavor but
because it definitely boosts up the
protein believe it or not there's about
15 grams of protein in every quarter cup
of nutritional yeast so it's an awesome
pantry staple protein in my books
nutritional yeast is also a great source
of vitamin b12 when it's fortified and
we know that both people who follow a
plant-based diet and people with PCOS
and insulin resistance do tend to have
lower levels of b12 some research also
suggests that vitamin b12 deficiency may
play a role in infertility so
considering that Sierra is a vegetarian
with PCOS who is trying to conceive I
would definitely pay attention to b12
other vegetarian sources of vitamin b12
besides nutritional yeast would include
dairy products eggs and fortified
cereals though for strict vegans
supplementation is almost always
recommended let's take a look at another
option okay so I love how accessible
these recipes are I'm glad that Sarah
isn't eating naked carbs and is
consistently pairing them with a source
of protein in this case chickpeas now if
I would have any suggestions maybe it
would just be to up some more of the low
GI veg throwing in some spinach or some
more bell peppers tomatoes green beans
etc all of that would help kind of bulk
this up and stretch the medium GI carbs
like the couscous but overall we've got
lots of low GI and medium GI carbs we've
got a good source of protein from the
chickpeas we got fiber from the sweet
potatoes and the avocado and healthy
fats in the avocado as well I also love
that she's just honoring her hunger and
fullness cues by eating until satisfied
and then transferring her leftovers to a
container for later
Sierra really does seem to me like a
natural intuitive eater so with that
said in general is this way of eating
balanced definitely
I mean Sierra did a great job putting
the recommendations made by her
dietitian into action honestly I am so
proud and she's not even my client she
didn't eat her
carbs naked and she chose higher quality
carbohydrate foods that had a low to
medium glycemic index my recommendation
for Sierra would be to simply add in a
little bit more veg to her meals just
for the extra fiber and antioxidants
that they provide but again I think
cierra really does appreciate that small
manageable changes are way more
sustainable in the long run and I think
she's taking some amazing strides to
help manage her PCOS Sierra also scenes
in tune with her own hunger and fullness
signals and on more than one occasion we
saw that she ate until she was satisfied
without feeling the need to clean her
plate this is super intuitive and a
great sign the diet culture isn't
weighing in I know many of us grow up
with the idea that we need to clean our
plate and this sets us up to rely on
external fullness cues like an empty
clean plate as opposed to internal
fullness cues I talk a lot more about
intuitive eating and feeling your
fullness in this video which you can
check out right here now next are there
any problematic claims or assumptions
made by this channel honestly no
complaints from me I mean for once
usually this is a pretty lengthy section
in my videos to get through but I really
think Sierra approaches her body and
food from a place of care and it's clear
that she aims to nourish herself in a
safe and sustainable way without
restriction we also never really hear
any problematic diet e-language or
misinformed health claims from her
whatsoever she seems to predominantly
rely on the sound advice from her
dietitian as well as her own body's
innate hunger and fullness cues Sierra
you deserve every one of those million
plus followers and so much more finally
what can we take away from Sierra's
channel oh my god so much I am now truly
a fan so thank you to all of my
followers who recommended that I check
Sierra out now one thing that really
drew me into reviewing Sierra's channel
was about how vocal she was about body
positivity and promoting self love and
accept
since these are such important messages
that I don't think we hear enough of and
having this type of representation on
YouTube and other social media platforms
is so imperative to creating an
inclusive and safe space for bodies of
all shapes and sizes I also think Ciara
speaks so eloquently on these topics she
has clearly done a lot of reading and
has listened to dominant figures in the
body positive or hays movements and it's
so nice to see her sharing that
information in little digestible
anecdotes in each of her videos
[Music]
girl this is so important I am NOT gonna
watch the whole thing but Ciara talks
about dealing with internet trolls
criticizing her for gaining weight and
as soon as she came out as having PCOS
they all said oh I'm sorry it's okay
Lexia says youtube fans are not entitled
to any kind of explanation on why her
body is doing what it does I mean does
her weight impact the quality of the
content she's putting out
no is she spreading misinformation no
weight gain whether it's due to a
medical condition or not does not impact
your value as a person and of course
it's important to acknowledge that
weight is not just influenced by diet
exercise and lifestyle but it's also
important to acknowledge that even if
something like a medical condition is
not at fault for your body changing it
still doesn't have any bearing on one's
value or moral character
[Music]
yes girl preach I love this girl I mean
she's absolutely right and like I said I
think the girl has definitely done her
body positive research there have been
tons of studies showing that
metabolically healthy is not weight
dependent meaning you can be classified
as overweight and still be metabolically
healthier than someone who is classified
as being a normal weight weight and
health are not mutually exclusive so to
Sierra's point the assumption that you
can look at someone who is overweight
and decide that they're eating poorly
not exercising and are just
metabolically unhealthy is largely
outdated and has been debunked by
current literature also who is anyone
besides maybe your medical doctor to
decide if you are healthy or not sure
behaviors can be arguably unhealthy or
healthy for the general population like
smoking for example but someone's actual
health status regardless of their
behaviors or their appearance absolutely
cannot be determined by just taking a
quick glance some better and more
accurate indicators of someone's health
include physiological measures like
blood pressure cholesterol blood sugar
things like health behaviors like dye
quality eating habits smoking and
physical activity as well as
psychological outcomes like self esteem
and healthy body image and even still
while some health behaviors like smoking
for example can be labeled as unhealthy
for the general population
they don't necessarily make a person
unwell when we look at the whole picture
as far as I'm concerned weight is
nowhere near the most important
determinant of somebody's health
love this body acceptance is not about
letting yourself go as so many people
think but I think Sierra proves that
it's actually about self care and body
kindness which could include
eating and moving in a way that feels
good and supports your physical
emotional and mental health
I feel this 100% and while Sierra and I
have different experiences with PCOS
namely that I don't know what it's like
to live in a larger body I do know
exactly what it's like to be fighting to
love my body when I really just hate
that it won't work
the way it should you know women are
taught that our bodies really have just
a few main functions were to get
pregnant have babies and feed those
babies I have struggled with all of
those things and I've talked about my
struggles and getting pregnant and I've
talked about my struggles staying
pregnant and I've talked about my
struggles breastfeeding
none of which came naturally to me at
all I have had to fight like like Sierra
is fighting right now so I know that
feeling of knowing that you need to
treat your body well with nutritious
food and supplements and exercise while
also just being so mad that it won't do
what we've been taught it's supposed to
do I know that I'm on the other side but
I will never forget that anger and
disdain that I have felt for my own
broken body so I totally get where
Sierra's coming from in another one of
Sierra's videos entitled learning to
love my body again from my lowest point
she describes her journey in trying to
love and accept her body after her
recent miscarriage which understandably
resulted in a lot of body distrust and
disappointment
Sierra then drafts up a plan that will
help her show her body respect and love
despite her heartache and spoiler alert
weight loss is not even on the list so
let's discuss some of the things that
she came up with so number one was
making sure she's taking her prenatal
omega-3 and b12 supplements as well as
for PCOS medication so consistently
taking the right medication and
supplements definitely will help improve
Sierra symptoms which may be a really
important step for helping her to feel
good in her body the Omega threes are
not only a really important vitamin for
managing PCOS symptoms as we've already
discussed but they've also been shown to
help reduce anxiety and depression which
I know often comes with the infertility
and miscarriages perience I'm also glad
to see that she's taking a vitamin b12
supplement as well both as a general
recommendation for those on a
plant-based diet but also for mood and
PCOS management as like I mentioned
previously women with PCOS tend to have
lower levels of vitamin b12 which may
play a role in infertility number two
she's making sure to hydrate so Sierra
is making it super convenient and easy
for herself to meet her fluid needs by
using a measurable water tumbler and
refilling it a few times a day this will
definitely help Sierra balance her mood
while also helping her to feel more
energized and when you feel physically
good it's a lot easier to emotionally
feel good too number three is getting in
her exercised falling out of your
regular workout routine is such a normal
response to any kind of major life event
this pandemic is a great example
never mind something truly heartbreaking
like miscarriage or infertility Sierra
describes feeling a bit intimidated by
the idea of jumping in too fast or too
soon with her workouts so I think her
idea to start with some daily walks is
an amazing manageable plan not only is
walking great for PCOS symptoms by
helping with blood sugar management but
it also is a proven way to boost energy
and mood now number four is eating
nourishing foods and for this I actually
want to show a quick clip
you
I don't even have to say anything
because Sierra just nailed it to be
sustainable for most people at least
healthy eating should be the end goal in
itself not something you just do to
change your body and I love how specific
and sustainable her goals are she talks
about some of the baby steps she's
planning to take knowing that taking on
too much too fast is just gonna flop
this is basically what I see all the
time you know a meat lover goes vegan
hoping to lose weight or a carb lover
cuts out all the bread and obviously has
completely thrown in the towel on all of
their changes a week later so for
example like we saw earlier she had a
goal to eat breakfast every day starts
with a manageable rx bar and then
gradually builds from there another one
a Sierra's manageable nutrition goals is
to have one serving of steamed
vegetables each day throwing some frozen
or fresh veg into a pod or the microwave
is an easy achievable way to sneak those
veg in when the thought of making some
complicated salad or a roasted veggie
side dish seems too daunting I think
this is really great advice for anyone
who's trying to start eating more
vegetables without getting overwhelmed
overall I think this is a perfect
example of gentle nutrition and meeting
yourself where you are it can definitely
be even more overwhelming when you're
dealing with life changes and health
issues so kudos to Sierra for being
patient and kind with herself and
practicing self-love her next idea was
to incorporate more positive influences
and affirmations love this idea so
Sierra described cleaning up her social
media feeds by removing content that
didn't feel supportive and instead
following more body-positive
influencers that inspire her to continue
on her body positive journey and this is
great advice in fact research suggests
that viewing idealized appearance
focused content on social media is
associated with poorer body image and
low self-esteem meanwhile other research
has found that when women were exposed
to body-positive Instagram posts they
reported feeling more satisfied with
their bodies
more appreciative of their unique
functions and had a more positive mood
while the opposite was true for women
who viewed idealized Instagram posts she
also talks about putting up positive
affirmations on her mirror so things
like my worth is not tied to my weight
or I am capable of great things
interestingly science has shown that
self affirmations can have a positive
effect on the brain by improving the
neural pathways associated with positive
valuation and self related information
processing so it's no surprise that self
affirmations have also been shown to
help reduce stress and negative thoughts
so I think this is a great idea for a
lot of people myself included faking it
until you make it by verbally telling
yourself great things about yourself
while looking in the mirror might
actually eventually help you believe
them and finally she acknowledges her
body with a fun photo shoot I don't
think I can watch Ciara without a huge
smile on my face her positivity is
infectious and you can totally see her
mood and confidence built throughout
this video culminating in the super fun
photo shoot
Ciara you are an amazing woman and an
amazing role model for so many women and
men out there who are struggling with
body and security infertility or just
general sadness in difficult times I
think that these steps here could be
applied in so many different settings
including just the general funk that so
many of us are in due to social
isolation bottom line I know this video
isn't exactly like my typical what I in
a day reviews and I know that it's long
and I've actually been actively trying
to cut these things down but honestly I
just had so much good I wanted to say I
could have just sat here and played you
Sierra's full videos like on repeat
because I think they're just so valuable
but instead I do recommend you go to her
channel like as soon as you finish
liking and commenting on this channel to
go check it out sierra so much of what
you said resonated with me as you know
we both have very similar infertility
journeys
but your resilience and sense of self
love and acceptance is so amazingly
inspiring I know that the next time that
I face a roadblock thanks to my body
whether that's due to breast feeding
around - or a future pregnancy or just
really anything in life I am totally
going to revisit your videos as
inspiration to get through when it comes
to nutrition
I think Sierra is doing a great job her
meals are looking balanced they're
sustainable they're not restrictive and
she's approaching her meal planning
gently from a place of self-love not
changing her body and finally the body
positive language and focus on healthy
behaviors not body size and weight is so
refreshing in the YouTube space
definitely go give this girl a big
subscribe and a virtual hug and that is
all for me today folks again please be
kind of the comments both on my channel
and on Sierra's but if you like this
video please be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a compa lo with who
you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and I will see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]
you
[Music]